indeed when we say incredible it's
because it's hard for us to believe it
happened the way it did carissa a win
like this one you see your opponent play
a move like night before you were geared
up for a tremendous fight and then
suddenly this appears on the board your
reaction to this kind of blunder
i mean at first i thought like i
hallucinated something i was like is
ricky for even really winning so i had
to take a
few minutes to kind of uh
double check everything but um
i mean it's a very pleasant thing when
your opponent just kind of blunders and
you don't have to
fight it out for like another two hours
so you don't feel sorry for her or
anything you just thanks for the point
yeah i mean i've got got a lot of
homework to do you know so
i had to finish up quickly here
okay uh the opening itself was very
sharp how much of it did you prepare
i mean i wasn't expecting um
the carocon at all and then i was kind
of like
you know what i'll just play e5 for fun
because i haven't really played it
before and i was hoping that
since i hadn't seen irena play it before
hoping she wouldn't really know what to
do either and we would just like get out
a book and i think that's what happened
but
right you played this idea of queen to
a4 and then continued sharply with c4 so
you were not necessarily familiar with
the nuances of this position you were
just playing chess right here
yeah i mean i was just kind of uh
kind of doing whatever you know i was
like c4 looks good queen e4 looks good
you know open up the center but she's
not castled yet and i can like have more
space so it should be better for me
there were some sharp lines that started
breaking out once your rook
landed d4 something that yasser was
mentioning was possible obviously a
number of variations were possible there
uh
as yasser points out one way that the
game could have gone
we did see
a position
right around here g4 starts to become an
idea were you ever looking at it
um
g4 right not necessarily the this moment
g4 is a move at this moment but were you
starting to look at any moves like f4g
for trapping the bishop with f5 yeah
definitely um
i would have to calculate a little bit
because there's always like knight takes
e5 stuff
but i thought like h6 was a
reasonable response because like g4 is a
pretty big flare so
and when your rook landed on d7
what was your assessment here did you
feel like
i'm starting to cook
yeah i felt like i was definitely
pressing here but uh
i probably misplayed it a little bit
after like bishop before here maybe roxy
one isn't necessarily the best
but um i usually like to stay ahead of
the
clock
in my games so
i couldn't really spend too much time on
this one position i thought i was like
rick c1 looks good enough i could get
into like a slightly better end game
so you saw so you saw the end game
coming what did you have for rook c1
bishop c3 queen a2
um
i mean i didn't really look too closely
at queen a2 honestly because i thought i
mean i should be able to take on like b7
with my queen or rook right
and it looks a little iffy for her if
you're playing against the assassin you
always have to look at lines that
involve your pawn being captured
[Laughter]
nice yeah it does turn out that queen b7
goes into some wild uh crazy lines along
the seventh rank
uh and then the end game came on
and how do you evaluate
this position is bishop e4 you play
bishop f1 after clearly some thought
retreating the bishop is not necessarily
the party move
[Music]
how did you feel here slight advantage
or
um yeah i mean i thought i had a slight
advantage and i could press a little bit
eventually get my queen side pawns
rolling
and um
yeah i mean with bishop f1 i just want
to threaten rick takes b7 because i mean
i was looking at all sorts of lines of
like
a3 or bishop c5 or like rick d1 even to
try to keep brooks on the board
with two pairs of ricks on the board but
um yeah i mean i thought bishop f1
thrown b7 and then we'll see how she
reacts and then figure out a game plan
from there yeah well it turned out to be
a fantastic move was it she prompted
knight to b4 blunder
you are in
first place now by yourself of course
there are games that are pending
your aspirations coming into this
tournament
how do they look right now versus when
you first came to play
i mean i'm always hoping to win every
year but uh
i don't really have any
expectations of it i guess so you just
beat the eight-time champ i mean your
main rival
yes i mean
um
there's still a lot of other people who
could catch up i mean irena could still
catch up if i falter eventually so i'm
just trying to keep it like one game at
a time still
all right professional attitude go get
your homework done thank you
congratulations carissa indeed good luck
with the homework i'm just quickly